carnegie-mellon really chose me um but
after i after i came here and decided to
come here I realized that Carnegie
Mellon was really perfect because it's
the only University in the country with
a top-notch drama conservatory program
that I could attend but also have a
biology degree and be very serious in
the sciences and that was the only
program in existence really for me I
knew that I couldn't just study sciences
when I came here and I knew that I
couldn't just study theater when I came
here I had these two sort of
irreconcilable parts of me that I had to
use both of and and I have always loved
science even though I've not been a very
natural science it's always been sort of
the subject that I have the most trouble
in and but I've always loved it because
it's the especially biology because it's
the study of life right it's the study
of how humans I mean humans and the
processes that govern us work drama also
for me is also been the study of life
and has also been the study of people
and that's sort of how I've been looking
at my education here is that they both
make up the human being you know or life
because in drama you're studying people
and you're studying their interactions
and you're studying their emotions and
you're studying sort of one aspect of
how people work and and how life works
but then in biology are also looking at
how life works they're just completely
different angles well I'm working on my
thesis project right now and that is
this whole mix of things but it's
supposed to be a way it's a it's a
performance it's cooking show
performance and the the objective of the
cooking show performance is to use
performance and art and theater in order
to educate people about scientific
processes and culture and agriculture so
that's sort of been a really nice fusion
because I think the drama and the sides
come together really in terms of
Education using theater elements to
educate about science I think food as a
way to educate is a really wonderful
medium because everyone needs to eat and
a lot of people who have a culinary
sense of adventure can learn about
a new culture that they might not be
aware of or it could be a forum or a
vehicle to discuss things that maybe
weren't so easy to discuss before
conflict kitchen is a takeout window
that sells cuisine from countries that
the u.s. is in conflict with first we
did the Iran and then we did Afghanistan
and we're doing I've got a son right now
and then I think we'll be moving into
Venezuela but it's just been a really
wonderful opportunity because a lot of
people from the community and a lot of
people from all over Pittsburgh come to
our takeout window because they've heard
about us and we've been featured I mean
complications been featured at NPR and
all these great you know international
journals and I guess I think people
liked the idea so much is because it's a
really unique way to approach awareness
and educating people I know that
whatever I do will involve food travel
and education now that sounds very
ambiguous and it sounds sort of idyllic
but I think I think same use given me
the confidence to know that that is very
possible that I can take a lot of facets
of myself and make them work together
and not be afraid or not be worried for
the future the prospect of speaking in
front of my class well the class that
I've spent the last four years with is
such a big honor and and how could I not
want to take that opportunity to sort of
speak with them I I I was at president
Cohen's house a few nights ago for a
dinner that he held for our class and
when I was eating and walking among
people and socializing I thought wow
this is my class this is these are the
people that I'll be talking to and it's
really amazing to compare that group of
people with the group of people I met
during Playfair there's so much more
them I think than they were before and
that's really beautiful so we've been
through a lot we've studied a lot we've
done so many things together and I am
just very honored and I wanted to have
that honor so I called it Koren quieten
which is a fairly fancy word that I like
it's Latin
heart and quiet Tim is like unquiet or
restless and I remember that really
striking me I saw that during freshman
year that phrase really striking me
because I thought oh well what a lovely
way to say what a lovely way to sort of
put a title on our on our tendencies to
want to go for things or want things
that we have this restless heart and
that we need to fulfill it and you know
core also is like the core courage comes
from courage and then ku is French for
heart cortisone quite a phone is a heart
and Spanish so I I thought let me talk
about the heart and sort of the center
of who we are because that's something
we all have in common right